Nên một tháng 7 năm ngày khu chăm ha miếng hạt động tên của mọi người chính quyền 2 cóp, một sự kịch lix sự đặc biệt quan trọng của dân tộc.
Tại vì năm Quốc tự thêm phố Chí Minh và các trụ sở từ Việt thuộc giáo hội và cháo Việt Nam đã từ hành nghi tức cầu Quốc phải dân ăn.
Tại tránh định Việt Nam Quốc tự, lúc sau giờ, bà hội chương trống bắt nhá được gửi lên, hoa thượng thích lệ tra phó chủ tịch hội đồng chỉ sự.
Chương bán nghĩ lẽ chú ước, chương bán chỉ sự giáo hội và cháo Việt Nam thành phố Chí Minh mới nếu hương cầu nguyện,
con chư tăng và tự tự tự kệ y tức cầu nguyện.
Theo hòa tự tích lệ tra, chú trống bắt nhá là pháp em biểu hiện lời dệ của đứa vật lưu luôn với quan những cảm giố,
đang tức trái tình của những lại.
Hí an sang tình tức có mặt trong ý tức của mỗi người thì chúng ta mới có thể hiện dự hộ đau và chuyên hóa khổ đau.
Chuyên hóa những nghiên tố bất an thành điều tốt đẹp.
Sao ngon này, nghe một tháng 7 năm ngày khu chăm ha miếng lắm,
là ngày tòa tế bộ máy hành chính của Quốc gia đi và vào đậu theo chú chương mới thì gọi 1 máy,
vẫn hành tham mua hình chính quyền 2 cấp.
Đà phật cố chí tình thành hoa quyết, nghiệp nhanh và đồng hành cùng chú chương của nhà nước và hưởng lời khai khí của hộ đồng chí sự.
Và lúc sau giờ sáng, các tụi lâm tử vệ, với 3 mi tư giáo hội và giao Việt Nam tình thành bối trong cả nước đồng là cửa 3 hội chú chống bắt nhá.
Bởi nghĩ là tình và sáng lâm đề chứng mình cho sự kiện trọng đại của sinh tập,
một bước hoặc lượng mới để đi vào kỳ nhuyên.
Kỳ nhuyên của Hòa Bình của tiên tụ,
hòa tự trường 3 chỉ sự nói về ý nghĩa của Hòa Lê,
Hòa tự cố kêu hỏi chứ tăng,
phật tự thân sự Hòa Lê nó lục tụ tập tình truyên để chế tắt nên năng lượng mình in cho tự tất cả hình tạo năng lượng an lệnh đó để mọi người vào mọi loại với lời chúc an là.
Bình đất nước luôn thành bình, nhân dân luôn an là,
để dân tục bình a mỗi ngày mỗi phát triển bước mạnh.